There is no such thing as freedom in North Korea
I heard my father kneeled down and
told me to earn a part during the 6.25 war. Oh, why don't you do anything when you use it for a long time
?  Oh, what a bee wealth, or a pretty face, I
keep monitoring when I go out.
Well, I mean, I was too burdened even when I was an adult,
so I came out now
.  When you get
hungry again while riding, you eat whatever you give, eat fertilizer, whatever you do
when you can't go to a singer lead, then eat it and then the
price is also safflower If you go to another house, you still have food, but why do you see our house in
the middle
?  Since I came out of the case study, there is no such thing as freedom in North Korea. There is nothing called freedom in the
bubble. Freedom of the press. Orthodox freedom
. Bubbles are donated to everyone, but you can't do
anything
you want.
I can only go there with the oath of oath issued by , but I was a bit young at the time
and there was no such thing
When I joined Rin for 10 yards
, I started pretending to be together like this, and I started pretending to be together like this, Hae-ryeong 1, Gyeonggi-do.
Once I settled in, it was long. I
went out to other things that were not good for the information. So I had a
sense of antipathy. So, it is the first place  Well, I've never said anything like this in South Korea.
In North Korea, they say gangsters.
That's why I started participating and my friends joined the group together, so I'm going to be active
.  And then we protect them, then
mobs get them and
don't do it like this What Joe Elephant Talking about himself Georgies like this organization Met 2
They're just doing what they want, then what do we do with our own wishes
We don't protect it with the government, but then I don't think we've  It gets bigger and bigger, and then I smuggle it into the middle.
First of all, the first Kumho TV in Japan. The answer starts with refrigerated pouches,
then
there, when it's done, then gold plated 4
What's next, then with you in the winter and something like that  It was really cold, and
then the biggest thing started was that big centipede, frost, smuggled it into our car.
So then there were those Japanese girls, and then we brought other fabrics for children
and when we were having a really hard time, we crossed China in the first place.
At that time, I went and cut the jacket a bit early, but after doing that a bit more, you are not good at farming in Won,
and it is difficult to come. In the commentary, there are Korean orthodox teachers.
If I asked you to see me, I did
everything I
could to get my bum to go over again by hand, so after seeing the end of the river,
how much did the teacher go out to
my neck and help me check it out in North Korea?
I have a large amount of land, and I raise the tips. Lavis r Like this tomato
So uh oh yeah 5 weeks, I drank once a week, I got it regularly twice
After this has passed, believe the plan. What is it? It’s a
real one. It’s more like waking up $10,000. When
you
start thinking like this  I started to believe in something because God listened to me,
and I started doing it, and I did it
first and studied for life for a year and six months, and
then the associate teacher told me to go back to North Korea,
so I got qualifications in the broadcast and if I try again, I will be in
China.  After I was baptized, something was damaged, so I removed it all
and became a Voca
When the North Korean gang anticipate the crackdown on crackdown, I did everything
Kim Jong-il started as a nickname, and
at that time in g, what was the case in North Korea?
If you believed in God, you ate gauze right away, and if you don’t sprinkle it,
you go to a political prison camp Yes, it’s
obvious in the United States.
It's been six months since I've had it,
and first of all, if I'm going to say the law in a North Korean cell, I get
busy, smoke a lot of felt, go to a chair like this, and believe
it, I'm at the same limit as I. It's not what
I did.  When we say that the door tools used by ships,
it's like this, a piece of wood, a ten-seated piece of wood,
then a sieve pipe, and then,
behind the leather, when the people turn twenty-two when they turn twenty-two, when they love it all the time
.  It's said to be given to me in the dry season, after rice,
6 noodles,
one cycle like you or something like that, or a rope, that's all, 5, that's
right
Oh, he doesn’t burn because I know my parts for 6 months,
so Daewoo is uh huh, look, 3rd The
Eve What, Jung-gu earns a leader and is in the middle of a waste  I said that I was born with the colonel on the way, and that
was the first time that the storage kid was the size of a cap dew, so
I finally took a blank sheet of paper to the
bathroom, and then asked the question at the bottom of the bathroom.
There were a lot of trains in North Korea, which belonged to another 60 kilograms.
So, if it fell right away, it would be a bunch of
Tuman River, and it seemed like I had put the Tuman River right around the time I was going to learn
.  I almost went over it, but at that time the train cow was given and I became one of those hurricanes, I gave the
hard work and left a bit
of a self-sufficient
sentry and all came out.
I got it, come out. I can't come because I'm
doing the repairs, so I can't come, half of it is in the North Port. I'm telling you half of this to the Chinese land, but
I'm going to go ahead and
connect
it.  I did it for a year, and the burden was concretely recovered and blown up, and
finally, in 2011 0 what month, what did I do financially?
You were the only fist enlightener. Uh
, I looked at the bylaws at first, and I started again, so I told
them to change their senses, but
what could be the meaning of Bangkok, Thailand? Entering the Immigration Service camp under the United Nations.
That
14 Imoogi is so I can’t sell it, so I can’t sell it, so it’s been about a year as I remember when the US was on and off.
He added help,
2 temps, then it's not like mad cad, but
cas, it's $
200 and then it's 5
rent  I applied for 6 months like this, and after 6 months it just passed, I was
sent to take care of
myself. From the sound of a lot of stairs on the ela side, even if it was very short, it would be a statement of entry.
There is no challenge, first, biblically speaking, there
is a neung region, spring Onggi came from North Chungcheong Province, went to North Korea to give a church or something,
but
North Koreans want to know God Jesus more. Now there is a dehumidifier.
There are 299 people like that, too, and there is a group that goes to Blue Dragon Island, so the
skill is
uh, there were a lot of L’s friends, and at this time, I only went out to supervise
.
There is nothing 2 0 1 1 First of all, I have to
pay three times for housing expenses, so I have nothing to fear.
South Korea is Namu people. Looking at it this way, Khan is not adorned as a democracy with light and same-sex always
state.
Democracy of Democracy, speech, Democracy,
Sang-woo Kwon, of course, this is the wrong way to transplant that baby food into the country that served during this period
.
I know that I hoped because I saw it, so I know I’m okay with having a child, Bajina-san, if it
’s actually going to cost up to sub tp, I know well that North Korea is a cancer-
prone company.
If the people of the world
knew exactly, well, the world
will say the last thing.